[Música]
y yo de momento hablar de economía en
directo américa de france 24 y hasta
conmigo lista en el estudio daniela
blandón danny comenzamos por supuesto
hablando de estas sanciones contra rusia
porque europa tocaría por una vez la
energía de rusia en sus sanciones así de
raúl muy buenos días pues a este nuevo
paquete que se está discutiendo en la
unión europea' prohibiría la importación
de carbón sin descartar medidas también
contra el petróleo y el gas escuchemos
que dice ursula von der leyen
estas sanciones no serán las últimas
como ya dije ayer yes we can holt a si
prohibimos el carbón pero ahora tenemos
que investigar el petróleo y tendremos
que analizar los ingresos que obtiene
rusia de los combustibles fósiles
realmente tenemos que hacer un esfuerzo
para que limitemos la fuente de ingresos
de rusia de los combustibles fósiles
tiene que haber un final a eso y este es
el siguiente paso que tenemos que dar
juventud after shave to get up
danny que tan importante es el carbón en
este caso nos mire europa tiene aliados
como eeuu colombia sudáfrica
australia y canadá para suplirle este
carbón que le proporciona hoy rusia ya
que le compra hoy en día unos 4000
millones de euros al año y esto es una
cifra que no es realmente significativa
si se compara con las importaciones de
petróleo y gas que pueden oscilar entre
500 y 1000 millones de euros por día
estamos hablando de que el carbón que
compra la unión europea equivale apenas
a un 1% de lo que compra en los otros
productos energéticos y rusia lo que
dice es que denunciará estas sanciones
económicas en los tribunales
internacionales y daniela siguen los
temores de que rusia podría afrontar un
default porque claro la explicación es
la siguiente raúl el lunes venció el
plazo para que rusia pagara vencimientos
por alrededor de 650 millones de dólares
a los tenedores de su deuda soberana el
departamento del tesoro de eeuu había
estado permitiendo que el gobierno ruso
pues usara sus reservas de divisas en
instituciones financieras en ese país
para realizar esta clase de pagos y así
lo había hecho en el pasado
desde el lunes ya no es posible y se
teme que esta vez si entre en default al
no poder acceder a sus reservas y que
desee rusia el ministerio de finanzas
ruso dijo que ha decidido hacer el pago
en rublos de estos 2 eurobonos porque el
pago fue rechazado por uno de los bancos
en el extranjero que es el que tiene las
divisas uno de los que tienen las
divisas lo que sí reconoció es que en
teoría podría encontrarse en un
incumplimiento aunque señala que sería
una situación artificial porque el
dinero si existe pero está en rublos y
no en euros o como debe ser el kremlin
agregó que continuará pagando su deuda
externa en rublos mientras sus reservas
de divisas permanezcan bloqueadas por
las sanciones internacionales algo
parecido a lo que sucedió con el gas que
rusia desde me lo tienen que pagar en
rublos claro y la unión europa dice que
no se lo pagó en euros hablemos de
dinero que nos afecta a nosotros sobre
todo que vivimos aquí en colombia ni ya
hizo mercado este mes lo hice ayer y que
sorprendida otra vez como el mes pasado
yo lo tengo que hacer este mes yo lo
tengo que hacer hoy o mañana porque ya
casi que no tengo comida y no quiero ni
saber es que en este país el aumento de
los precios no atraigan no no la traigo
a raúl y es que el alto costo de los
alimentos y soy testigo de eso es
culpable de este repunte inusual en los
precios de la canasta básica en general
según el departamento de estadísticas de
este país estamos en un nivel
inflacionario raúl que no se veía desde
2016 sólo en marzo el índice de precios
al consumidor aumentó un 8 53 por ciento
frente al mismo mes del año pasado en
ese momento o sea hace un año los
precios no subían más del 2% de lo que
se ha mantenido en los últimos años en
colombia los alimentos y las bebidas no
alcohólicas subieron más del 25 por
ciento en apenas un año y un ejemplo de
ello raúl las papas a usted le gusta la
papa me fascinan las papas las mire más
que duplicaron su valor en apenas un año
y esto por que daniela que se está
haciendo para controlar estos precios en
el mercado ya el gobierno del bando que
ha venido bajando los aranceles a
algunos insumos agropecuarios pero más
allá de esto está a presión
inflacionaria lo que causa es que el
banco de la república tenga que seguir
subiendo las tasas de interés como ya lo
ha hecho en los dos meses anteriores con
las consecuencias que esto trae los
bolsillos pues es karen se encarece el
costo para acceder a los créditos y la
cifra del día es alentadora o también
voy a terminar llorando esta crónica de
economía bueno no la cifra es simpática
le tengo novedades de la lista forbes
2022 en la que ya hemos dicho muchas
veces nunca vamos a aparecer mejor que
aparecen las personas que tienen más de
mil millones de dólares pues mire la
pandemia sigo el poder los
multimillonarios aunque no lo crean ahí
este año dos mil 668 en el ranking anual
87 - que en 2021 también la fortuna
conjunta de ellos es de 12 a 7 billones
de dólares casi medio billón menos que
hace un año las caídas más dramáticas
estuvieron en rusia sin embargo raúl más
de 1000 personas y se hicieron más ricas
el año pasado y también hay 236 recién
llegados incluida rihanna el ranking
ahora se lo digo y lo hemos que el dueño
de tesla que se ubicó en la cima por
primera vez mientras que jeff bezos el
fundador de amazon cayó al segundo
puesto por primera vez en cuatro años
pero bueno si el mono siempre yo sabía
que este año día estará obviamente de
primero bueno han y entonces muchísimas
gracias nos vemos más adelante con más
economía pasamos a ver nuestro reportaje
que es en perú